but let's let's jump on in um i like
throwing a curveball at the beginning
you obviously have directed a number of
things if you could get the financing to
direct anything you want make any
project you want what would you make and
why
you is that um like a film
that that is made or like
anything you want
anything it's like you know the dream
project
so i think it will be a mixture of
interstellar
featuring uh
pirates of the caribbean and uh
man of steel
oh i do love man of steel yeah i i yeah
man of steel was one of my yeah most oh
and to be honest okay number one in the
world like a director i would love to
work with anyway is like steven
spielberg and i loved et you know like
et was you know my
my child and uh
yeah but
i think everything that has a sense of
dreaming big
that it's very entertaining is a genre
film and it's like um
uh and it's like
yeah it feels like a
very pathetic big huge film you know um
yeah that's that's what i would love to
do
uh so getting into some specific stuff
in the film how the hell did you pull
off that bike sequence where um
obviously it's not you but how did you
film that because that's really tough
yeah so we had uh uh thank you for
asking because uh that was
you know when we did the location tour
and when we made this decision for to do
like a bike chase in the film um we we
went through a whole proc and then we
found out all these crazy stairs and
they were like really
that was a tricky tricky tr these are
tricky stairs and uh
even even to go to even go up
to the stairs that was like that hurt
that was hurting like hell but even you
know down was very it was terrific so um
i called zach and debbie and i told them
about the bike chase in prague and uh
debbie said matthias you will not do
your own stunts on these days and uh so
yeah we we were building like um we had
like three guys like really good
bike ride you know they could really
like they
they were married to their bikes so uh
um
but we were building like a
tiny track like a ramp and a track on
the stairs so i could be on a on the
bike so uh and some of the stunts i did
by myself
yeah listen it look it looks very cool
in the movie um i love nicholas cage and
there's a lot of nicholas cage
references in this movie did you have to
actually get his permission to use his
name and like the jokes with him or was
it something like like it's like a you
you don't have to do something like that
oh yeah to be honest uh that wasn't
that's not my department but it's uh
um i heard that that we have to have his
permission i don't know it was a manager
or it was
the film
i don't know where uh what the
distributor was but uh um so but i heard
that we needed his permission and on
these
what is it like 10 seconds in the film
you know like uh
um so uh yeah so i heard that we needed
his permission and we
there was a yes and it's in the film so
i'm really proud because uh even that
film you know it's uh it was like one of
my movies you know
from my past when i was a
a young dude
100
um i love talking about editing because
that's where the movie all comes
together did you have like a much longer
first cut what did you learn in the
editing room uh that maybe surprised you
alex
berner the guy who the editor of the
film um we had a great time because i
learned
a lot with that film because
um when i came back from prague and we
met in in the editing room um
he told me hey matthias what do you
think about to to
to cut all this film together without
any music
no
no music it's just let's do it silent
just acting uh dialogue but nothing else
no music
and i thought hey that's a that's a
great idea that's uh
yeah come on let's do so the first three
cuts
it was just a film
without any music and i loved that that
was so good and i learned so much about
you know rhythm and
and because if the scene works without
any music you don't have to cheat you
know you don't need music that the scene
is good and uh that was a cool process i
learned a lot
um i you are uh i've been to berlin a
number of times this is not where i was
gonna i was gonna ask you but [ __ ] it um
i love the city uh for people that have
never been there what do you want people
to what do you want to recommend to
people to do if they only have one day
in berlin
i think it to
to really focus on the historical
foundation of the whole city you know
like
uh driving with a cab from the east to
the west from the west to the east and
different places like
checkpoint charlie and uh looking at all
these spots of this um very
modern but very historic place so
discover the wall discover the old
hitler bunkers discover
yeah even like how the coffee shops
changed in the west and the east you
know like um
and it's it's still there it's beautiful
yeah um we could really get into this i
i went to
east berlin has really changed a lot in
the last few years i'll say it i'll say
it like that
yeah a lot
a lot especially i mean i think
it feels newer than than the west to be
honest with you know like uh it's so and
i'm from the east you know i saw berlin
when it was really gray gray gray when
the war was still up uh that was a crazy
time
uh do you know what you're actually
going to do next do you know what the
next film you might direct
i have an idea
but nothing really nothing i can talk
about but
cross fingers that it will be something
like an
english film
and english speaking film you know like
uh this would be cool
on that note i'm just gonna say congrats
i hope the movie is a huge hit for you
thank you so much for your time
thank you so much thank you and safe
travels
yes thank you and you too
you